attacking the rim like a carnival tie
stereotypes
now let's go to your X IJ Ogilvy get
suddenly the guy at the heart would love
to see start taking up
melih girl will that count into david
anderson has a mismatch and he fires it
- bald - picks it up look away but
weirdly tan and good
created that opportunity for Ashley
because of the help side big had to get
at Thomas Abercrombie Anderson knocks
down another long two on the baseline
amount of ball and transition
[Applause]
Malibu's now 1 for 7
now you get all the way sets up the
defense that time he just draws enough
to get the finish to fit Delaney the
better go and spawn Karina are putting
the official to jump it out of the lock
this she would
one of six
[Applause]
David Anderson the veteran knocks down
the three Dan Shamir and although the
people will be looking at the breakers
wrinkled but the way this league has
been going together Wow yeah just some
of the hustle play starting go to the
[Applause]
[Music]
line
tried to financially on the trial he
comes ball
[Applause]
second Abercrombie unless you know about
it but you're already running back bull
with a two-man gang to Illawarra he's
trying to get his own tricky bit on the
dots bills that will do it for a
triple-double
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pull launch field for three
that's a to its eternity
[Music]
[Applause]
boy
[Music]
the deficit they have to come back to
the little ball
[Music]
subin assure you
red
now lord
crosses Oxford Delaney found the contact
nn-now there is poised what mental
fortitude
with domination in the closing minutes
led by SEC head room of
my goodness that's funny